septembre 2017 j'ai pris mon envol pour
découvrir une ville surprenante
berlin capitale au passé tourmenté qui
aujourd'hui une des villes les plus
dingues plus connaissent deux jours à
berlin ou suffisent à dire ai-je dit un
père les nerfs
cette célèbre phrase a été prononcée par
john fitzgerald kennedy le 26 juin 1963
bien plus qu'un simple soutien apporté
aux berlinois pendant la guerre froide
c'est aujourd'hui à lesage
d'appartenance à tous ceux qui rejettent
aujourd'hui et plus que jamais toute
oppression tout lourd et tout
enfermement
[Musique]
berlin ces deals contrastée ce contredit
en permanence tantôt chaudes tantôt
froides
elle affiche son ouverture d'esprit
comme cicatrices du passé pour ne jamais
oublier berlin grouille toutes parts
vélos voitures piétons se mélangent dans
un vacarme paisible
que ce soit en surface au plus profond
d'elle-même berlin va vite très vite
ces couloirs sont remplis d'histoires
que nul ne peut ignorer le berlin c'est
la force d'une ville qui a survécu pour
offrir le meilleur dans les dédales de
son histoire berlin fait émerger une
culture underground de l'électronique à
la itech de l'automobile à larchitecture
berlin attend pas offrir les choix
d'alain parce que le salon était qu'on
peut trouver au mois de septembre
lifar durant quelques jours va y avoir
tous les meilleurs produits de la high
tech à découvrir
[Musique]
3,5 millions d'habitants peuvent se
vanter de la peuplée aujourd'hui berlin
une des places fortes de l'europe 166
musée 142 bibliothèque 60 théâtre des
clubs renommés dans le monde entier
berlin est la capitale de main d'un gang
son style est unique
ces sonorités sont uniques sa techno
fait sa fierté ces clubs sont des
légendes le trésor le kitty le berghain
elle abrite en son sein le meilleur
d'électro
[Applaudissements]
o o
berlin est aujourd'hui reliés au monde
cf ban font voyager des millions curieux
qui viennent lui rendre visite
ces avenues ne désemplissent pas la vie
bouillonne est formé de toutes parts
[Musique]
en promenant j'ai fait des découvertes
incroyables des restaurants surprenant
des édifices tu majestueux ces
universités en ferait pâlir de jalousie
n'importe quelle ville française
[Musique]
des heures à arpenter berlin en long en
large et en travers
qu'il pleuve ou qu'il fasse beau berlin
rayonne partout temps
[Musique]
ans
à
oh
on
enfin berlin su prendre de la hauteur
pour se réinventer la capitale allemande
va sans cesse de l'avant dans un numéro
d'équilibriste à cheval entre son passé
son présent et son avenir
berlin su prendre le chemin de la
rédemption
[Musique]
malgré ces cicatrices la ville se
construit peu à peu pierre après pierre
[Musique]
autrefois l'un des points de passage
entre l'est et l'ouest
checkpoint charlie est aujourd'hui un
vestige du passé qui aime les touristes
étrangers
à la nuit tombée berlin offre un nouveau
visage
lander grande refait surface la vie
étudiante se mélange avec les clubbers
venus de tous horizons l'atmosphère
ressenti le jour
exulte la nuit il y règne une ambiance
étrange mêlant la fois un bouillon de
culture urbain a une soif intense de
croquer la nuit à pleines dents
ces avenues sont comme de longs tunnels
qui conduisent à l'émoi rien n'est
jamais identique mais rien n'est jamais
différents non plus la nuit berlin se
réinvente pour revivre ses heures
glorieuses 1,3 kilomètre du mur de la
honte reste encore debout comme pondent
pas oublier l'impensable celle où la
nuit du 12 au 13 août 1961 berlin était
coupée en deux et de 3,6 m les vestiges
du mur ont comme une cicatrice qu berlin
ne veut oublier
[Musique]
elle les a offerts aux artistes du monde
entier pour se réapproprier les
influences sont multiples et les oeuvres
monumentales le mur et la mémoire d'un
passé présent que l'on ne doit jamais
oublier
ne jamais perdre de vue l'essentiel le
respect des peuples à disposer d'eux
mêmes ne jamais lâcher prise devant la
tyrannie pour qu'il n'y ait plus jamais
de mur à berlin comme ailleurs
[Musique]
berlin merci pour ces quelques jours ont
accompagné qui nous permis de comprendre
ses heures à errer dans les rues au fil
de tes inspirations
voici mon hommage il est comme je t'ai
perçu underland et un sou monde je
n'oublierai pas ta bienveillance et te
promets de revenir bientôt
merci
[Musique]
oui
là